welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and Star Wars George Lucas's 1977
space opera revolutionized the way
Hollywood films were shot designed
scored marketed and consumed burning
nerdy passion projects about bickering
droids into mainstream obsessions
obsessions that you know these days are
now considered dead on arrival by the
very fans who claim to love them I don't
know about you but I'm tired of having
to temper each positive statement about
Star Wars with an acknowledgment of
recent installments divided receptions I
love it I wear this shirt under every
other shirt smells like a woman I don't
care and to remind myself and hopefully
you about how fortunate we are to have
this franchise in our lives I am going
back to the beginning with a full
in-depth rewatch and analysis of the
original Star Wars all the Easter eggs
cultural references visual details that
I'm only now singing because it's hard
to scrutinize this imagery through
playful baby boy tears it begins as
these always do a long time ago in a
galaxy far far away
Lucas's inspiration for Star Wars was a
fantasy adventure in the style of Flash
Gordon or Buck Rogers actually the
opening crawls and life transitions
where we're all taken from those serials
rather than the science fiction cinema
of the time best known as Stanley
Kubrick's 2001 a Space Odyssey Lucas's
story is pure fantasy setting in in
space doesn't make a sci-fi folks you
know what else is in space you mean us
right now everything is space a long
time ago is Lucas's way of setting that
fantasy tone a title of an early script
draft was the adventures of Luke
Starkiller as taken from the Journal of
the Wills saga won the Star Wars a
mouthful story the Journal of the Wills
refer to Lucas's old concept of the
Wills spiritual beings who tell these
stories as a kind of religious text the
draft centered around a Jedi Bindu named
mace windy in his apprentice CJ Thorpe
sounds like a guy who was on my swim
team in high school these details were
changed but later films called them back
of course with mace windu Starkiller
base in the force awakens and the
guardians of the Wills in group 1 on to
the famous opening crawl with Lucas's
original version reportedly stretching
to six paragraphs with forsen as as each
and was shortened it to another version
but the final version that we see in the
film was revised by Brian De Palma
director of Scarface and Carrie and good
friend of George Lucas's the original
1977 version was simply
old Star Wars but with the 1981 print of
the movie and all following versions
Lucas changed the title to Star Wars
Episode four a new hope to place it
smack in the middle of this whole
canonical timeline the storytelling
principle is called
an matias rests and it's consistent with
the way Star Wars follows beat for beat
the classic hero's journey
outlined by Joseph Campbell Lucas
reportedly read Campbell's hero with a
thousand faces between drafts of his
script and really Luke Skywalker story
is modeled on the story of King Arthur a
farm boy from humble beginnings meets a
Merlin figure wields a magical sword and
rescues the kingdom and we must
acknowledge the music composed so
masterfully by John Williams with
soaring symphonic swells inspired by the
classical music in space contrast of
2001 Williams main title theme was
actually inspired by the theme of the
1942 film Kings rose 4 by Erich Wolfgang
Korngold
and Williams's force theme was inspired
by the works of vogner yeah Williams
doesn't hide the fact that he gets his
stuff from a lot of other places but
make it all sing as the crawl drifts out
into the Stars blasting past us is the
tan tip for in hot pursuit by Darth
Vader's imperial star destroyer the
Devastator two ships that were not yet
named at this point but were retro
actively named this imagery of a
detailed seemingly never-ending
spacecraft filling the screen is
actually a homage to poo brick shot in
the discovery one in 2001 and it led to
my favorite gag in space balls and then
we get the first spoken lines of this
saga focusing the film's first half hour
on non-human characters it's actually a
pretty bold move at the time Lucas
actually deleted a number of first act
scenes with Luke watching the battle
from below and hanging out with friends
they called him war me but really Lucas
was taking influences from Japanese
samurai films like Akira Kurosawa's
Sendero and the relationship between
c-3po and r2d2 evolved from the two
bickering peasants tahe and - Chi Chi
and Kurosawa's the hidden fortress
actually hidden fortress Easter eggs
appear again throughout this film the
Imperial Quest design was based on a
Japanese family crest in Admiral ma t
almost said hidden fortress before Vader
memorably cuts him off your sad devotion
to that ancient religion has not helped
you conjure up the stolen data tapes or
given you clairvoyance enough to find
the rebels hidden portal 3 POS design
was inspired by the silver female robot
Maria and Fritz Lang's Metropolis
Threepio is gold but notice that his
right shin is sober originally he was
just given a mismatched leg as part of
Lucas's overall vision of a scrappy
lived-in world but later cannon was
actually updated to explain that in the
years between Revenge of the Sith in
this film a bomb was placed in three POS
leg and that leg had to be replaced but
the new part that was added was not
dipped in gold like the rest of him was
meanwhile Lucas came up with the name
r2d2 during post-production on his
previous film American Graffiti with the
sound crew asking for real number two of
the second dialogue track which came out
as could you get r2d2 for me
the rebels lose the shootout with the
stormtroopers whose namesake was the
Nazi paramilitary unit the Empire's
heartless imperialism
coldly efficient bureaucracy and officer
uniform design were all inspired by the
Nazis and along with Vader notice that
the Empire is always depicted in
monochrome shades designed as a contrast
to the earth tones worn by the rebels
and the Jedi enter the best villain of
film history Darth Vader the suit was
actually one of the many designs of
legendary artists Ralph McQuarrie
McQuarrie wanted Vader to be able to
breathe while he was traveling from his
ship to the tent at 4:00 thus his
breathing apparatus which would also
later be retroactive Lee explained
through different backstory he wears
robes similar to those worn by Bedouin
warriors James Earl Jones dubbed the
voiceover of physical performance by a
bodybuilder David Prowse and the
breathing sound effect was created by
the sound designer breathing through the
mask of a scuba regulator Leia hides a
drive with the Death Star plans on r2 in
Threepio worries spice in the Star Wars
universe is the generic term for drugs
and it's one of the many terms Lucas
lifted directly from Frank Herbert's
dune series along with things like
moisture farms and the voice which is a
controlling ability similar to the force
also a pretty cool spinny chair show we
actually see the spice mines of Kessel
that Threepio is worrying about in solo
a Star Wars story where Lando stroyed L
337 does get as three peel fears smashed
into who knows what and if you think
about who knows what is actually the
operating system of the Millennium
Falcon anyway Vader snaps the neck of
Captain Ramos Antilles entertains Leia
as three p1r to take an escape pod down
to the surface of Tatooine shot in
Tunisia its name actually comes from the
tunisian town of Tatooine spelled
differently in two dishes rural South
Threepio passes this skeleton now this
is the skeleton of a crate dragon in
this prop actually still lies in the
janeshia desert gonna go wander out
there and find it the Comics Star Wars
tales 15 sandstorm features a
ten-year-old Luke getting attacked by a
great dragon and a [ __ ] named young
Anakin and a fever dream leader in his
film the scream that obi-wan makes to
scare off the sand people is the roar of
a crate dragon but more on this later r2
gets taken by Jawas and he rejoins
Threepio and then they both get sold to
Luke Skywalker and his uncle Owen Lars
this moisture farm home like all the
sets in this film reflect what Lucas
called a used future Lucas commissioned
production designers John Barry and
Roger Christian after helping them
shovel salts as they were addressing
different movies salt factory set and
they had this idea of applying that
whole dirty factory look to all of Star
Wars one of the many things to make this
original trilogy so great as Threepio
gets his oil bath Luke plays with a
model of a t16 skyhopper this is the
vessel he piloted in beggars Canyon and
everybody gets to know each other you
can call me Luke
I see subdued that's just Luke
Threepio calling Luke sir is another nod
to the Arthurian legend influences and
four shadows of Luke's future as a Jedi
Knight shortly after this young hero
receives his call to adventure but like
all Farm kids Luke gets pressured to a
miserable life of sucking drops of water
from dirt it's only one more season yeah
Biggs refers do Biggs Darklighter Luke
sprint who went off to the Academy whom
Luke actually hung out with and those
deleted scenes for the special edition
Lucas added the reunion scene between
Luke and Biggs on the rebel base that
was not in the original version
audiences were a bit confused when Luke
reacted so dramatically to Biggs's death
next twin sunset Tatooine orbits a pair
of binary stars super heating the whole
planet so that it's only habitable at
its poles actually in 2015 NASA reported
that planets kepler 16b and kepler 453
beat orbit binary star systems just like
Tatooine does I would call this nature
reflecting arts but you know those NASA
nerds are just looking for any parallels
of Star Wars they can find while looking
for art to Luke in Threepio are attacked
by Tusken Raiders they write a bantha
the source of the blue milk that Luke
drinks this is actually an elephant
dressed in fur and fake horns some have
speculated that these tests can Raiders
attack Luke as revenge for his father
Anakin slaughtering them and Attack of
the Clones this is not confirmed it's
more likely that Tusken Raiders are just
dangerous and turf protective like
animals as they read the land speeder we
get this freaky moment
so this is obi-wan Kenobi faking the
roar of a crate dragon to try to scare
him off now what you just heard is the
most recent read of in the 2011 blu-ray
edition in the original 1977 version in
the 1997 special edition it was this and
then for whatever reason in the 2004 DVD
release Lucas updated it to this and
yeah now in 2011 it's this monstrosity
this is one of the many effects Luke is
updated throughout these continual recut
s' which has become a point of ire among
Star Wars original lists look for better
or worse part of the whole story of Star
Wars is Lucas's obsessive tinkering and
personally to me it represents an even
more fascinating narrative about whether
art should remain fixed or evolved I'll
come back to this throughout this
breakdown obi-wan saves Luke and calls
to r2 in the force awakens JJ Abrams
actually sampled Alec Guinness is lying
here to form the word Rey in that force
vision sequence obi-wan takes Luke back
to his home and tells them about his
relationship with his father I was once
a Jedi Knight the same as your father
first time we hear the word Jedi lucas
derived the word jedi from the japanese
words did i get ki which is a term for
the japanese soap opera that's set in
samurai times now notice the patch on
obi wan's right shoulder some have
suggested this could have been caused by
the burn marks obi-wan endured during
his battle with Anakin I'm used to far
now this would imply that obi-wan only
has one pair of robes laundry day must
be tough and to me the patch looks like
it's in a different spot but certainly
this duel is on Obi Wan's mind in this
moment there was a shot and Revenge of
the Sith where we see him in a close-up
picking up and against lightsaber which
would lead to this eventual handoff
father's lightsaber this is the weapon
of a Jedi Knight
an elegant weapon for a more civilized
age for over a thousand generations the
Jedi Knights were the guardians of peace
of justice in the Old Republic before
the dark times before the Empire the
oscar-winning sound effects for this
film were mixed by sound designer ben
burtt to produce the lightsaber hum
Burtt combine the hum of an idling 35
millimeter film projector with the
feedback of passing a stripped
microphone by a TV set nowadays the
sound effect is made by nerds in their
basement just really not to a furniture
then obi-wan explains to Luke though
force the force the force is what gives
a Jedi his path it's an energy field
created by all living things it
surrounds us and penetrates us it binds
the Galaxy together yeah all this cosmic
abstract language from this Merlin
figure related to this mythical weapon
definitely evokes the language that
Tolkien used when Gandalf was describing
the Ring of Power to Frodo
one ring to find them one ring
and Lucas's early drafts may the force
be with you was actually may the force
of leaders be with you and this was
before the force was detached from like
the collective will of a bunch of other
people to a more cosmic disembodied life
energy this is my force dance verse
after hearing Leah's distress call
notice these somewhat awkward edit going
on here as we go back and forth from
Luke to obi-wan you must learn the ways
of the force if you were to come with me
to Alderaan Alderaan yeah I would look
here you talking about old man the
reason for this awkwardness is actually
that the scene was cut up in reordered
in post-production it was shot so that
it begins with Leia's message and then
obi-wan tells Luke about his father in
the force that's why obi-wan is suddenly
leaning forward and talking about force
again when we come back to him if you
were to rillette at this you could
actually see how these puzzle pieces fit
less awkwardly before surrounds us
penetrates us it binds the Galaxy
together you must learn the ways of the
force if you were to come with me to
Alderaan now the reason this was changed
was probably the planet name of Alderaan
and Lucas wanting to have it been more
recently stated so audiences still
unfamiliar with Alderaan don't get to
throne see things like this is the
reason a lot of people are uneasy when
all the tinkering the filmmaking here is
imperfect but it's also still great
because it represents interesting
problem-solving that's what all of
filmmaking is in this slightly awkward
patch just like the one on Obi Wan's
robe is something that ought to be
preserved meanwhile Vader and Tarkin
meet with the Imperial officers
including poor Admiral mati who is
having a day I find your lack of faith
disturbing
notice that throughout the scene Grand
Moff Tarkin is always saying with his
lower legs covered because Peter
Cushing's costume boots didn't fit too
well and shot mostly steaks and slippers
Luke and obi-wan find the stormtroopers
have laid waste to the Jawas transport
as well as Luke's home and poor uncle
Owen and aunt Beru
their hard skeletons are the most vivid
Gore in my opinion that we will ever see
in a Star Wars film and this violence is
critical because at this stage of the
hero's journey Luke must be violently
shaken from his status quo ironically
Owen was afraid of Luke
I mean like his father when it was Owen
and Beru who suffered fates that are
most like those of Anakin Skywalker so
they head off to the spaceport at Mos
Eisley you will never find a more
wretched hive of scum and villainy or
one of more special edition CGI because
nothing showcases ILM magic like a big
ass walk in the main characters obi-wan
pulls off his Jedi Mind Tricks on the
stormtrooper and they head into the
cantina which George Lucas included as
an homage to the Sergio Leone a Western
trope of gunslingers and bars bartender
says we don't serve this bartender's
name is actually war and his hatred of
droids is explained in the book from a
certain point of view in which as a boy
he lost his parents at the hands of
battle droids during the Clone Wars
traumatising him unfortunately he's
surrounded by droid imagery on all sides
because one of those distillery pots
behind the bar was later reused as a
head of the ig-88 assassin in Empire
Strikes Back this canteen is great it
has a number of odd background
characters including men in NASA
astronaut suits with the patches covered
up the wolf man lacks zip rack whose
close up was removed in the special
edition but he could still seem in the
background and of course Ponda Baba and
dr. Abbas on who also appeared on Jeddah
and rogue one Obi Wan zoom up one of the
few times a lightsaber doesn't
immediately Carter eyes a wound again
the blood makes it real and great no
time for that we got another
introduction here originally George
Lucas planned the character of Han Solo
to be a huge green skinned monster with
no nose and kills but a slightly
handsomer Harrison Ford got the part by
reading sides during auditions after his
role in Lucas's American Graffiti his
co-pilot Chewbacca was based on Lucas's
Alaskan Malamutes dog named Indiana
Lucas was later used as a namesake for
Indiana Jones who also took his nickname
from his family dog for Chuy's wookie
growls Burtt combine the sounds made by
dogs and bears lions tigers and walruses
Han describes the Falcon it's a ship
that made the Kessel run in less than 12
parsecs famously this line has been
scrutinized for using a unit of distance
parsecs to describe time with maybe the
confusion coming from parsecs a lot of
guys do wear shirts like this have lives
they'll do confusion from parsecs but so
low a Star Wars story clarified this as
in fact not a fact error because
the Millennium Falcon speed is a factor
of its superior navigation system gained
from the OS of Lando's droid l3 37 which
expedited the shortest distance through
the dangerous Kessel run nebula han runs
in degree tow in the most infamous of
Lucas's re-edits originally Hans
argument with guido ends with hans
shooting grito from under the table
creating that's blind an explosion in
griot 2 slumps forward dead han coldly
walks out of the cantina it was awesome
no complaints but then the 1977 special
edition included a laughably bad VFX
insert of Greedo pointed a gun at han
grito firing first somehow missing him
feet away hitting the wall as Harrison
Ford's face awkwardly benched to the
side and then Han fires Lucas said that
he changed it because years later in his
mind Han I guess couldn't be a
cold-blooded killer if he was gonna
marry Leia and that he should be a more
noble John Wayne style cowboy who only
kills the self-defence yeah nope after
this backlash in the 2004 DVD release
onward
Han and Guido now shoot at roughly the
same time yeah ok they're gonna try to
laugh off this whole controversy and a
deleted scene from the Phantom Menace in
which a younger Ito shows up on Tatooine
in a fistfight with Anakin Skywalker
yeah good cut the 97 special edition
also added this scene with a CGI Jabba
the Hutt Matt Dover stand-in actor
Declan Mahal and a scene that was
deleted from the original Boba Fett was
also added here it was kind of cool to
see this in 97 now it seems kind of
weird cuz the CGI doesn't h2o but I do
like this moment when Han passes behind
Java and steps on his tail that weird
motion blur on Harrison Ford is due to
the fact that they had to animate the
original footage to have board step up
because board originally passed behind
Mulholland who of course was smaller
than Java and I couldn't have Ford
passed through Jabba's tail so that
created this gag to cover it again
clever problem-solving it's great just
don't tinker to create more problems in
the Falcon cockpit there's a pair of
golden dice hanging these were stolen
from the set
never replace an empire or Jedi but
these dice return is a major prop in the
last Jedi and solo a Star Wars story
they escaped from the stormtroopers
depart Tatooine and jump to Lightspeed
Tarkin threatens to blow up Leah's home
planet of Alderaan and Leia tells them
that the rebels are in the actually
deserted base on the planet that Dan
Sabinas actually
later appeared in the books an animated
series its evacuation was going to be
shown in row one row scrapped gonna be
too expensive and an early version the
force awakens was going to show the
planet Dan to may turn into the doom
star which was an early name for star
killer base so target blows up alter in
any way cuz he's a space Nazi and after
some hollow chess and religious debate
on board the Falcon they arrived to the
space Alderaan once was in an early
draft they were going to arrive at Cloud
City which would have been floating
above Alderaan at the time of the
explosion but the duel with Vader
happened on Cloud City and then things
move on to the Death Star but all this
was removed Cloud City was later reused
an empire and they approached the Death
Star leaving Luke to utter this
trademark line they escaped the search
by hiding in the floor compartment a
tactic that Rey and phantom later steal
in the force awakens they escaped with
stolen stormtrooper suits
notice that the stormtrooper armor
contains this tubular poster on the back
originally many of the stormtroopers
were also going to carry lightsabers but
at the time they were considered less
significant laser swords this would have
been where those swords were holstered
they escort Chewie to the detention
level where are you taking this ya dick
move by this officer by the way people
know what Whoopi's are anyway back to
the clip 1-1 3-8 is a nod to George
Lucas's previous film th X 1-1 3-8
and there's also a nod in Leia's cell
number 20 187 is the name of an abstract
1964 short film that lucas loved it
featured this influential voiceover
people feel that in sort of the
contemplation of nature and in
communication with other living things
they become aware of some kind of source
or something behind this apparent mask
it's interesting to consider this in the
context of masks in Star Wars
both Vader's and in more recent films
then whose first order ID was fn-2187
they rescue Leia and escape into the
trash compactor where Luke is attacked
by this tentacle monster this is named
the DNA gap and it began the trend of at
least one big gross creature in every
Star Wars film even if all it does is
breastfeed notice the hatch in this
trash compactor this is the same set
piece as the
airlock door from the tanta board it was
just painted white they had to reuse
sets to save production costs the
stormtroopers fine Threepio and r2
leading to this humorous mishap that
twink the stormtroopers head hitting the
door was added by Lucas in the special
edition because fans love this so much
contrary to the theory that the hit was
caused by poor helmet visibility the
actor claimed that he just had an upset
stomach that day obi-wan runs into Darth
Vader and their duel in comparison to
the more aggressive duels of later films
is slower it's more patient always two
hands on the hilts that's because Lucas
based this sword combat on the fight
choreography of samurai films which had
fewer more deliberate strikes
the only contact Princess Leia has at
obi-wan in this film is the brief moment
she witnesses the end of the duel they
escape thanks to obi-wan having disabled
the tractor beam leading to an intense
dogfight with the TIE fighters sound
designer bird produced the screen the
TIE fighter by combining the squeal of a
young elephant with the sound of a car
driving by on a rain-slicked Highway
between that banthas elephants getting a
lot of work in this movie Lucas took
inspiration for this dogfight along with
the trench run from world war ii cockpit
camera footage and world war ii arab
movies like dam Busters flying tigers
flying Leathernecks and the battle
britain the rebel base on Yavin 4 is
housed in the ancient great temple of
the Massassi built by the Massassi to
worship the Sith Lord Naga Sadow's
who enslaved and mutilated their race
Lucas shot all these scenes in Mayan
temples in Guatemala rebel leader Jan de
Dona
briefs the pilots on the Death Star
schematics the only computer animation
in the original cut this animation was
filmed on 35 millimeter and we are
projected and no one saved that original
animation so the designers of these
battle plans and rogue one had to
recreate it to perfectly match as the
Death Star closes in on Yavin 4
Vader utters this faithful line seen the
end of Kenobi soon
Vader was right of course but only
because the destruction of the Death
Star was the turning point that would
lead to the rebels no longer needing to
rebel in a way the beginning of the end
of the rebellion in this leads to one of
the finest sequences of filmmaking of
all time the trench run assault on the
Death Star
their attack strategy involves the
x-wing red squadron and the Y Wayne Gold
squadron gold was meant to charge down
the trench and hit the target while red
provided cover Vader saw through that
strategy and splitting it taking out the
white wings and forcing the x-wings to
take point
confirming the clue dropped by obi-wan
earlier about Luke's father now
originally an x-wing blue squadron was
going to be included here but the blue
paint on the vessels wouldn't have
worked on the blue screen that they used
to the VFX chromakey thus yrz choose
blue paneling appears d saturated during
the trench run now rogue one documents
the fate of the blue squadron and the
preceding battle of scare off' as well
as the vacancy of the red 5 position
which luke filled now as I mentioned
before George Lucas took a lot of
inspiration from the dam Busters in
which RAF bombers fly low to take out
heavily dependent reservoirs just like
all the rebel pilots do here the intense
quick cutting and point of view cockpit
shots were all taken directly from this
world war ii imagery which was an
aesthetic that every Star Wars film
since would later continue Lucas even
took dialogue from the dam Busters and
notice this line yeah he says this time
because in an earlier version of the
film Luke made to trench bombing
attempts with the first one failing that
first attempt was removed but the line
was kept in Luke he W wons voice and
uses the Force to guide his return
torpedoes in that plus a last-minute
save from han and chewie on the Falcon
allows this Arthurian hero to save the
kingdom in the end Leia awards Luke and
Han with medals metal that actually
comes back in the rise of Skywalker but
disgracefully Chewie is snubbed and the
only kind of official reason we've ever
received for Chewie not get in the
middle comes from the Marvel Comics
adaptation of the movie which explained
quote Chewbacca of course will have his
own medal but he will have to put it on
himself
do you space princesses or that tall
which
kind of just sounds like a passively
racist line from that d-bag officer on
the detention level where are you taking
this and credits but this Star Wars
rewatched ain't over folks I plan to
continue this series through the Empire
Strikes Back Return of the Jedi and the
prequels which put us just in time for
the rise of Skywalker releasing in
December so follow me on instagram and
twitter at Navis follow new rock stars
on socials subscribe to our podcast feed
WikiLeaks for early access to all of our
Star Wars content and of course
subscribe to new rock stars on YouTube
for breakdowns of everything you love
and hey hand me that metal because all I
ever want to do is touch a wookie there
hugs just seem therapeutic
[Music]